- [Narrator] Hello readers,
today I wanna talk to you
about why we read more
than one text on one topic.
And to show you why I shall use a subject
that is very near and dear to my heart,
animals that can kill you.
This is not a joke.
I legitimately wrote a book
about this a few years ago,
and to research this book
about the world's deadliest animals,
I read a lot of other books and sources.
So I wanna use this experience
to show you why it's
important to read more than
one source on a subject.
Okay, so why do it?
Why not say all right,
I read one text about the
Pacific Blue-ringed octopus.
Why do I need to read two or three or 20?
There are a couple reasons.
Let's start with the
first, expert knowledge.
If you wanna know all about octopuses,
you can't just look at a
single piece of writing say,
"Bam, got it, know all I need to know
"I am the knower of octopus facts."
No, you can't do it.
If you want to become an expert,
you need to be able to
say well, this book says
the Pacific octopus toxin
can stop your heart.
But this one says that
you can tell whether
or not an octopus is
frightened by its color.
Reason number two to
read multiple sources,
helping to determine or know what's true.
Sometimes people get things wrong.
It helps to read more
than one text to make sure
you're getting as many
perspectives or ideas as you can.
Sometimes information from an old book
might be outdated or
information from a new book
hasn't yet been proven to be true.
Reading different texts
can help you decide
what you think about a topic,
or even whether or not something is true.
We can answer questions like,
what is the deadliest animal?
Or how do we even define deadliest?
Reason number three,
to read multiple texts on the same topic,
supporting an argument.
The more information you
can get about a topic,
the more support you can give
to your own opinions or arguments.
I think that this animal
is the most dangerous
because I've read a
bunch of different works
about dangerous animals
and I can support it with
evidence, you would say.
If I were to say that
bears are more dangerous
than I don't really know what I drew,
I thought I was trying to draw a sheep
but I think it's a hedgehog.
If I were to try to argue that bears
are more dangerous than hedgehogs,
I would use multiple sources
to provide evidence for those claims.
Bears are taller, bears are heavier,
bears have sharper teeth,
bears are stronger.
Hedgehogs or sheep are cuter
and cuddlier sorry to bears.
It's important to recognize
that different books
have different arguments in them.
Every book has a different angle, right?
Sometimes it's obvious
like a book with the title,
"Deadly animals and how to hunt them"
versus a book called
"Deadly animals and how to
protect their habitats."
People have opinions
and people make books.
So, that means that books
can have opinions too.
Are these animals cool or terrifying?
Should they be hunted or protected?
Reading one text on a subject
doesn't give you the full story.
It's important to be able
to read more than one text,
compare them and then decide
what you think from that.
It helps to have a purpose
in mind too as you read.
Oh, and to answer your unspoken question,
the deadliest animals on earth
are definitely human beings
but in a close second place is hippos.
Those guys will bite you in half.
So you know, watch out for hippos.
You can learn anything. David out.